[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
all right then hey here's the thing you
guys may not know painkillers is they
work
really this week and you have my back i
have my ruptured disc in my back and
then
i had some painkillers and i of course
didn't want to take any because i didn't
want to be loopy today right right uh
and then uh i i hit the deck like an old
man so i apologize if you see me during
this
it's not a commercial for imodium it's
just my background by the way
you know he's doing commercials for
modium beverly mitchell the middle
sister from seventh heaven or as i call
her
disgusting i was gonna i was just gonna
ask who is doing commercials for imodium
beverly mitchell okay
is now doing commercials for imodium
like on instagram people like look look
at my yoga pants look at jim shark and
she's like
diarrhea medicine i can stop myself from
pooping
you're so regular fire your sales rep
lady
take what you can get stephen we have a
lot to get to today we will be
this is the start of fraud week we told
you that yeah talking about fraud and
election irregularities i know we
covered it as it came in but a lot of
you were saying hey what's happening on
a state-to-state basis
we need sort of a catalog so we will do
a catalog today starting with dominion
voting systems
oh boy not a conspiracy there's a lot of
tom flurry going on there and then we'll
go into georgia michigan pennsylvania
day by day and upload the crowder bit so
that you can share them with your
friends who will no longer be friends
with you but
you don't have to worry because
thanksgiving has been cancelled
no worries today is my half-assing
laravel richmond and dave landau of
compound media
hello everyone hi hello father christmas
hello that's what they call me this is
the
white robe i don't think that any of our
robes on air should ever be white
yeah i feel a little uncomfortable
because i can see the article in the new
york post
and his uh one of the co-hosts who
donned a white robe
does that actually have a hood on him
[Music]
it's just a turtleneck robe now
combining that with a white surgical map
that's not good
oh my god just stop three breaths all
right quarter black garrett is here
audio wade is here
gerald is here how are you i am well get
me pain pills and
um what we have breakfast
anything else we were told that of
course it was a conspiracy theory but uh
this is
breaking from uh my homeland and i'm
very ashamed i'm sorry oh by the way
we'll also be talking about can you get
covered twice the science says
no so can you get covered twice dominion
voting of course the violence in uh dc
from antifa these are the topics we'll
be covering today and then
we'll be playing steven no sports and
taking your chat at mug club this is
going to be fun but first
the prime minister of my country were
you were
you were getting a little loose with the
terminology here it is country yeah yeah
canada uh had this
to say about the pandemic and the great
reset
building back better means getting
support to the most vulnerable while
maintaining our momentum on reaching the
2030 agenda
for sustainable development and the sdgs
canada is here to listen and to help
this pandemic has provided an
opportunity
for a reset this is our chance to
accelerate our pre-pandemic efforts
to reimagine economic systems that
actually address global challenges like
extreme poverty inequality and climate
change
reset it's happening here's what
here's the thing if you if you go out
and you make a statement
that immediately could just be rebutted
by the craziest
deep wormhole of conspiracies q anon
alex jones
verbatim and you couldn't fact-check
that person that's a horrible statement
it really is dependent on you provide us
the opportunity for a great
reset for global economies and then he
mentions the un
that's not a good idea well and i think
i'm pretty sure that he morse code
blinked
bilderberg it doesn't help that he looks
like the bad guy from equilibrium
the guy who's like in the tv like
telling you like big brother this is
what's going on
and why is their camera so shitty i know
i mean the country
it's cobra they don't have they don't
have high speed yet yeah
no i love how he's like we're here to
listen yes because nobody cares what you
say
we are here to listen go ahead and talk
and
four viewers in the live stream hold on
a second i want to talk on my skype and
mother get off the phone isn't he just
proving freudian slip right it's like
literally the top of the greet reset
says do not mention great retakes
you get removed if you were to mention
the great reset or globalists
on youtube and he's the one who says it
maybe he's playing 8d chess who knows no
maybe he knows that people are going to
react and he's like that's exactly
what i expected no no no this is justin
they were like if he mentions it they
know for sure we would not let him into
the great recess right this guy's an
idiot
if he knows about it then it's
definitely not real speaking of reset
before we move on uh tax filings
have now revealed that uh joe biden had
a cancer charity okay
that uh raised millions and spent
millions on salaries
uh zero on actual research really
nothing on
actual research from joe biden here's
something else when we read this story i
remember i was thinking uh and dave i
don't know if you're like a political
junkie but i remember when barack obama
was running for president they were
looking into charitable donations
between mccain just a junkie
and even i was like wasn't joe biden the
least charitable politician ever and we
do we have the
records uh he only gave 369 dollars a
year to charity over the course
of a decade so cancer research
a decade cancer research charity that
gives no money to research
and over a decade he gave three thousand
let me do the math here three thousand
six hundred ninety dollars total to
charity and so
right now here on ladder with crowder by
the power of mug club combined
i right now
i'm going to do more for charity in
cancer than joe biden never has we
donated
3 691
children cancers research fund all for
salaries though
more generous than your potential
president
combined you'll save no one yes nobody
and i know you shouldn't give to charity
out of spite you should but
yeah no you know i think the kids
actually appreciate the spite dollars
they come with a certain energy a
blanket yeah a kid with
come on kids with progerians can't be
choosers
that's true wow i don't know if that's
what you call progeria progeria it's not
a country i
don't know everyone's a community now
it's a community
we're a community we're a people of
color community we're a queer community
we're an amputee community you were just
talking about that on your show
and hathaway with the witch hands yes
she had to apologize
to the lust club yeah basically i can't
even think of the name because it was
the stupidest
limb list they called them just like
limless something yeah
yeah it offended limbless people
different limb different
lynn's difference thank you yes a limb
different meaning you have less fingers
that's that is different yeah so
hopefully they're right yes flip
it's flipper it's lobster claw hands
yeah exactly and she's like i can surf
it's like wow you can do stuff in the
water that's a shock
all right so we do have to talk about
vodafone but first please do consider
following me on instagram that's where
you get the lifestyle stuff and i do not
sell
imodium that's beverly mitchell so uh do
consider following on instagram there
look there's my dog joe lewis he's nice
and uh of course uh mug club is what
makes all this possible out of
credit.com
mug club consider joining crowder
election stream is still a live code
because the election
is not over and my question is to you
people this is kind of we're
crowdsourcing this do you know if your
state uses dominion voting machines and
uh what was your experience when you
went and voted did you use that machine
do you know because
there's a lot of information out there
that's anecdotal but pooled together
we might actually be able to help uh get
to the bottom of this a little bit
absolutely
um finally let's get to the million
march maga million march and the
violence that happened in dc
um don't you love how when when you know
the election was uh
potentially allegedly stolen from donald
trump uh there were no
violent eruptions in the street at all
it wasn't mostly peaceful protests it
was entirely
peaceful protest right and then there
was the maga million march
and then antifa shows up and then the
proud bush and then of course there's a
clash it becomes like the jets and the
sharks
again yes a lot of snapping and dancing
a lot of snapping
yeah the gayest gangs ever yes did you
see i can do a muscle up well first
that's impressive
but we know tony that you want to bang
riff you have no interest in burritos
to be he just had a thing for puerto
ricans and they weren't interested
oh no you could tell instead of the
teardrop tattoo they just had white
oh no did that count
a glimmer in their eye just that little
sheen they looked like an
anime cartoon uh so antifa black lives
matter they attacked a bunch of
trump protesters at the mogan now listen
no one is blameless here but i do want
to be clear
this is the first video that circulated
that you likely saw
at the maga million march that donald
trump retweeted which the left says was
taken out of context but i'm going to
provide you with more context here's the
first clip donald trump retweeted
oh
all right okay so there you go and they
pray for the gentleman which is uh very
nice but um
so just to be clear this is what donald
trump retweeted and then people on the
left were saying well it was taken out
of context right here's the whole clip
but they actually then provided
yet just a longer clip that was equally
selectively edited
so here is the clip that is circulating
on the leftist
talk shows right now i want you to see
it
taking his megaphone they shove him
shove him he trips over him here
now people are swarming him for people
who are listening on audio
shoving people complain that he shoved
women we'll come back to that
he gets kicked in the back
[Applause]
so now you see as he pushes them away
now the conflict is over
he starts to walk away someone's been
biting his time sucker punch
okay all right that's enough people have
seen that and then you see those they
were saying oh he was pushing women you
know that lady i don't know if yuck yuck
is in
that little orange shower cap it matched
his jacket
yeah exactly that's what she was mad
about she's like we we were not supposed
to coordinate
how are they gonna know who's on what
side if we're not the same
i'm wearing orange i don't care if
you're going hunting you got your shitty
little vests
just put it in my thing orange shower
cap yeah
matter of fact y'all could call me on
shower cap we're not going to call you
that ah
think about it give me your jacket
i want this to coordinate oh yeah
my cat yo jacket i got it going oh
no so to be clear a lot of people were
arrested here okay including the man who
got sucker punched there because uh he
also committed assault through
shoving but i do think it's important to
note through context he didn't punch
anybody there he was shoving people
repeatedly the left was getting really
mad saying can you believe that he
shoved women
here's the thing those two women uh i
noticed when i saw them in this clip
i have seen many clips from washington
dc in every single instance where
throughout the day by the way and you
can see because you can watch these
clips and see as the sun sets some are
daylight some are dark
all day any time that someone was being
assaulted by an ant for rioter
they just happen to show up like say
their name three times say
orange shower cap in the mirror three
times and they show up just swinging
me back i'm a [ __ ] so they've got like
season pass tickets on this
i think not how the rules were oh man we
have a montage
of these broads throughout the day let's
show it and find out
there they are okay
look different lighting so it's clearly
hours later
this is an old lady who gets assaulted
oh there's your own shower cap
oh i see here wow
again sucker punch the guy from behind
there you go still patrolling with the
gang just
two innocent ladies going on their merry
way for a stroll
pink boots the other one's got pink okay
[Applause]
yeah yeah they grab a taser and then i'm
pretty sure they follow this guy into
the parking garage
look at this yeah there you go there you
go there's pink hood
and finally there they are when justice
is served
yes there you go and i know i know i get
it
do you guys think that justice is racist
whatever
uh look at those cops did you see how
they were uh shooting and assaulting
yeah absolutely which if those ladies
had tasers and had been committing
assaults they would have been well
within their rights you know to put do
at least a little little
neon belly you know give a little bit of
an arm lock and like hey don't move just
make it unpleasant
got a little bit yeah i'm not saying i'm
not saying a violation everything but
i'm saying
i think that if you commit a violent
assault being arrested should generally
be an unpleasant experience the most
racist thing i've ever heard
pretty much i also believe that prison
should generally be uncomfortable
how dare you wow i know wow
controversial i know
you could not i should not be saying
that we have a gentleman with a white
robe
who's also been in prison 13 times
and look at him he does not fare well in
prison no i am a prison tent
[Laughter]
they're like you gotta quit breaking the
stitches i'm like i'm not the one doing
it
you're probably probably more
experienced with orange shower caps than
anyone in that indeed i don't know
here's your standard issue though i
really wouldn't
really my concern if i were you wouldn't
be so much about your hair getting wet
i know you don't like that the humidity
makes it frizzy but
there are going to be some other pains
for you
uh by the way the guy there who sucker
punched him kenneth de berry
uh he was charged with disorderly
conduct inciting violence aggravated
assault and being a felon in possession
of a firearm he's also a registered sex
offender
who sexually abused a child under 16.
how does that happen
i don't i don't think that you could
find as many registered sex offenders
drunk at the registered sex offender
watch party right
like i don't think you can find so many
registered sex offenders at a nambla
convention
right yeah anywhere you go kyle
rittenhouse shoots two people were both
of them sex offenders at least one of
them was at least one of them once again
jacob blake
this guy come on oh my gosh was it jacob
lake coming back to resex offense yes
yes yes
he was going for round two exactly they
don't even use the term
repeat offender because he does it so
often they save words just going he's a
re-sex offender
there's a whole different category you
got to adequately label these people i
mean just as there's your repeat
offenders
then you're resex offenders and there's
mvp right yeah this is exactly by the
way let's let's see uh
cnn before we go to uh something really
quick on our fraud week
uh there is rudy giuliani what are they
talking about they're attacking
giuliani's character and
they're going to commercial well let's
see if they attack sydney powell because
no one can argue with her legitimacy
we're gonna be talking about that a
little bit so
we told you that we were going to
dissect the different instances of fraud
and break them down by state but before
we do that today is the initiation of
this
we need to talk about the macro uh
problem with the dominion voter systems
it is time to kick off fraud week
[Music]
and then and then the line goes down
that's our country yeah oh uh and
actually right now we do have
as we do this all week um our
on-the-ground correspondent
thomas finnegan uh with fraud week and
some facts regarding fraud thomas
finnegan can you hear me sir
good morning steven i can hear you fine
all right well we can't see you let's
let's move the cam yeah move the camera
up thomas finnegan
move the camera up please let's angle
the camera up because we're just looking
at your chest
let's look up a little more yeah a
little no we don't have you thomas
thomas there you go stand back okay no
whoever is operating the camera is
really really dumb
and deserves to lose that's a great
spartan armor vest though that is a
great spartan armor vest
but that's not important right now angle
up a bit yeah
hand tilt the camera up
tilt it off
up thomas finnegan give us some fraud
facts here for fraud week
yeah all right uh stephen this is really
exciting it's a beautiful morning out
i just wanted to go through a few quick
facts for you
basically uh you know it
the family of frogs a grouping you might
you might say is called an
army of frogs and uh they're amphibians
uh composing of you know the the order
of anurah which means
tailless and ancient no uh thomas thomas
can you hear me it's uh it's
it's it's fraud week fraud with a d
yeah as in uh daryl
uh all week
yes all week it's fr it's fr yeah
nothing about frogs at all
for the entire week okay all right well
thank you thomas finnegan we'll check
back in with you tomorrow yeah okay
okay okay all right thank you thomas uh
he was wearing by the way spartan armor
vest for people who want to know correct
uh i don't have it's a website spartan
what is the website it doesn't say it on
here spartan armor
system spartan armor systems and uh
their bulletproof vests are actually
nij certified a lot of people say
they're nij equivalent he's actually
spartan armor is actually nij certified
if thomas finnegan doesn't do his
research he's going to need
yes so we may use the crowded promo code
you get 10
off sales and we actually use them quite
a bit so we make sure to give dave some
just to make sure yeah that's the one
that was shot yes all right so
now it'll be again oh well
now i don't appreciate it look they're
not good at everything though i still
feel very
insulted by my mother every time i talk
to her even when i'm wearing the armor
oh there are limitations too they don't
protect feelings the insults go over
very true and let's make sure that the
orange shower cap lady doesn't get me
okay you can shut off the skype there
quarterback
so let's go really quickly talking about
uh election fraud uh
election irregularities and election
fraud they're talking about giuliani
okay of course on cnn because they try
and say look giuliani's crazy even
though anyone who lived in new york
thanked god for giuliani anyone who
lives in the country
who looked at the actual declining
national crime rate said thank god for
giuliani
people out there i know a lot of you are
millennials a lot of you are generation
z
look into giuliani in the mob okay not
only 911 giuliani got to that position
by effectively destroying the mafia
people don't understand that this guy
was
very qualified but i understand
sometimes now there's a little bit of
the effect where
he goes all in the evidence isn't as big
as maybe sometimes he claims but sydney
powell
is about as legitimate as they come
about as credible as they come she's the
one who swooped
in basically was a part of the defense
team that uh proved michael flynn was
innocent
she talked about specifically we've
talked about ballots uh
poll watchers we've talked about ballots
being harvested we've talked about
them not following the constitutional
parameters but there is another
component
to this and we don't know i want to be
clear we don't know that there is
massive fraud occurring from dominion
voting systems
and there is some misinformation out
there both from the left and the right
however
this attorney who works with the trump
administration sidney powell researcher
look up her credibility
had this to say yesterday regarding
dominion voting
we're fixing to overturn the results of
the election in multiple states
and president trump won by not just
hundreds of thousands of votes but by
millions of votes
that were shifted by this software that
was designed expressly for that
purpose we have sworn witness testimony
of why the software was designed it was
designed to
rig elections he was fully briefed on it
he saw it happen
in other countries it was exported
internationally for profit
by the people that are behind smartmatic
and dominion they did this
on purpose it was calculated they've
done it before
we have evidence from 2016 in california
we have so much evidence i feel like
it's coming in through a fire hose
um whoa to be clear this is not a woman
who typically uh makes claims that she
can't prove
or dresses like cory let me be clear she
never makes claims she can't prove right
she's
you're a lawyer isn't she standing
attorney with impeccable credibility
in terms of not only her credentials but
the different fights that she's had
right i mean there are tons of attorneys
are i mean every attorney i know has a
ton of respect for her
and the types of things that she's
looking at and certainly we're only
seeing the tip of the iceberg right
recognizing what she's even allowed to
talk about now versus the strategy of
the things
that they're going to get into and
really this is something you covered i
want to say week maybe like during the
week of the election
was we talked about the different
connections the actually exporting it
internationally and the software
these are all different facts that have
already been verified and she's putting
them all together in this particular
she has a crazy winning record i think a
lot of people said would you put her
like if
she were an athlete because we'll play
stephen no sports later would she be a
michael jordan or wayne gretzky
i mean i'm not hiring her to be a family
law attorney because that's a different
thing or a hand
model yeah i mean definitely definitely
she's all yeah she's not going to
roberts no what
probert should be a pro yet an enforcer
a few old hockey fans remember
from st louis i do want to go but let me
hit you with a few quick facts as to
the actual uh history of dominion and
then we'll get into some of the errors
inconsistencies that we've seen with
this election so this is
these are all verifiable the sources are
available at loudoutcrider.com we'll
have the link below
in the description i want you guys to
look this up
okay because there have been some people
who've tried to use benford's law
misleading and say oh look at these
switched votes i think dr shiva or
something is one
that's something that's easily debunked
a lot of these things aren't necessarily
true it's very easy to use statistics
to mislead people and i don't want to do
that so what i want to do is provide you
with
a snapshot a history lesson on dominion
what it is
who they are and then we'll get to what
has happened this election so dominion
one of their
uh one of their lobbyists for dominion
is actually pelosi's former chief of
staff
and was listed as a clinton foundation i
was gonna say that's a fast overlay a
clinton foundation donor
25 to 50 000 now that's not definitive
anything i just want to
lay out a case here texas rejected using
the dominion voting system in 2019
they said multiple hardware and software
issues that preclude the office
of the texas secretary of state from
determining that the democracy suite 5.5
a system satisfies each of the voting
system requirements set forth in the
texas election code
here's another fast fact for you in case
you think you're just a bunch of crazy
right wingers in 2019
democrat senators uh elizabeth
pocahontas warn amy klobuchar
and ron wyden one of these things is not
like the other yeah
like everyone who's going wrong run hey
i'm here too
guys absolutely all right you're like
the third witch in hocus pocus
but eventually you got a walk-on role in
sex in the city so you know someone
recognized you
that's terrible ron wyden we need to get
ron wyden on the show yeah
no we don't somewhere richard painter's
going hey where
he's still in my spot you don't have
that
[Laughter]
you're silly all right never mind
amy klobuchar elizabeth warren ron wyden
issued a complaint about dominion
referencing
allegations of vote switching and other
undisclosed vulnerabilities writing
quote these problems threaten the
integrity
of our elections by the way we're going
to go of course to bill and uh
half-assing lawyer bill and gerald
morgan but hit the notification bell if
you are subscribed on youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot the
notifications let you know when
something goes up here and on crowder
bits and of course we do good morning
mug club monday
through thursday uh every week 10 a.m
eastern
um this is this is something i think a
lot of people who want to try and paint
this now is oh
it's just you know monday morning
quarterback from republicans this is
something that
everyone was concerned about and some
could argue even more so democrats back
in the day i mean there's no question
that this was a bipartisan concern
multiple states multiple voting
jurisdictions and authorities
people from both parties were saying
hold on
wait a minute this system might not be
exactly the way we need it to be
now when you combine that with the new
information that's coming out about
the votes that aren't matching with
what's coming out of the system how
there's these types of irregularities
at the very least there has to be an
investigation
to go through all of these different
questions and answer them even if you're
a democrat
if you really believe in the system then
you know that the system will withstand
scrutiny
and all we're saying is scrutiny yeah
but even further than that the
idea that we're going to just simply
walk away from one of the most important
elections
going down one path with one candidate
and a very different path with a
different candidate we got
let's say we do this okay and joe biden
wins and if he wins fair and square i
understand but i
do not trust any other elections going
forward this is the issue and i think
many americans do
half of america doesn't believe that joe
biden won the presidency
we've already seen so many
irregularities this is not like any
other election i don't think anyone here
ever contested again like we said
romney mccain bush gore i even remember
like oh well they called it fergor until
there was a 37 days
none of those were super controversial
this is very different and it's
widespread and systemic
something else too in august 2020 uh
data security expert i hope i'm saying
this right hari hursty warned that the
minion voting machines could be hacked
um you just talked about how you could
just modify a few lines of code yeah uh
when they were doing a mock election
they were basically saying that you
could almost drag and drop
put whatever results you actually wanted
into this election oh
that day and the election day and the
week before the election right-wing
propaganda outlet uh
and wonderful goose steppers pbs
reported on the vulnerabilities of
dominion they found that the qr
codes could be hacked candidates names
could randomly disappear
but like levar burton pbs says usually
he points to a six-year-old
boy who's more credible than him for
some reason you don't have to take my
word for it
but election security experts working
for the plaintiffs in the lawsuit
against the state
have uncovered several troubling issues
alex halderman looked closely at the qr
codes
where the votes are encoded for the
scanner by analyzing the structure of
the qr codes
i've been able to learn that there's
nothing that stops an attacker
from just duplicating one and the
duplicates
the same as the original barcode
and in late september another concern
came to light
during testing election workers found
half the names of the 21 candidates for
senate
intermittently disappeared from screens
during the review phase
really what about ron wein what was the
name
ron wyden what happened with
you know who listens to pbs newshour
how did trey how did trump get to you
how did trump get to you pbs i like how
nonchalantly they said that last part
and by the way
uh names disappear yeah still looking
into that i don't know
by the way people you voted for
are not what do you mean they're just
not they're
not a thing we don't know um i mean how
is this
this is unreal now let me get to what's
exactly happened this election just to
be clear so this is
free election right this is the stuff
that we have all the concerns that we
had covered we talked about potentially
compromised votes and this was one of
those sort of
i guess intangibles where you go i don't
know how much fraud there could be we
can look at the ballots that were you
know absentee ballots people who were
not supposed to be on voter rolls people
who were in different states all but
this is just one of those things we
can't account for oh and by the way
we don't know how many but the system
where everyone pretty much
votes then you just switch your vote
yeah so
there's that i mean it's it's almost at
this point like people are forgetting
that
it's undisputed that this already had a
demonstrated problem yeah
they're not forgetting they're ignoring
it right right right or they're thinking
that
that everyone else is going to forget
again it's just not saying oh well
hypothetically it could possibly happen
which maybe you could argue from some of
the stuff earlier well sure they were
saying hypothetically we're going to
solve it
and hypothetically we can fix it and
then you just go
to a week and a half ago and realize it
actually did already happen in michigan
oh there's a problem yeah and this is
the same machine that voted elizabeth
warren to being an indian
yes wow very happy are we surprised are
we surprised that technology is hackable
like is this breaking news really
i mean seriously i mean come on and they
did a movie about this or a documentary
i should say with that guy who said you
just change a few lines of code he went
in
and bought one of these machines hacked
it put the card in and said vote for
whoever you want
okay he flipped all of their votes yeah
on purpose to show them
this could happen like this is not news
you know i would almost we should have
known this he flips the votes he did
that's almost disconcerting it's really
easy to hack
a mailing ballot to somebody that
disagrees with you yeah yeah
that's that's the kind of thing so
you're a trump voter huh yeah someone
walks up to the blm shirt and an ant for
patch and you're like
hey yeah you're gonna get this vote
where i get it where it's supposed to go
yeah yeah when you hold up your vote
like this and he's like oh yeah we
got you it's filed filed yes yeah they
just throw it right at you
yeah you got it hold on a second wait
hold on
are you making a paper plane and that's
not
this is illegal is that a plane
i don't know why they just make two
towers out of your neighbor's ballots
they're playing jenga with kent county
from grand rapids
that's the republican counter
so is this why pennsylvania took so long
to count
there are so many reasons pennsylvania
took so long river like an italian
i don't know if there are any italians
left in flames i'm half italian are you
really so you can say it
you really couldn't have done very well
in prison being half italian and not in
the mosque oh they wouldn't even let me
in the nice room where you got the big
bread
i just raped you in an orange shower cap
yep that's it
so uh michigan so now let's get to what
has actually happened that's
circumstantial that's a speculation
people saying hey this could happen
again democrats and pbs saying this
could happen
at election specifically with this
voting software and sydney powell saying
we have proof that it has happened
that we haven't necessarily revealed yet
well here's what's publicly available
michigan a county using
dominion systems flipped blue this was
the six thousand votes that switched
from biden to uh donald trump
uh now they said though it's because one
of the clerks
forgot to update the software and then i
had also heard reports that the clerks
just didn't update the tally i'm going
hold on a second
shouldn't i mean my iphone like it
updates automatically and if i don't
update automatically it says you want me
to remind you later and i say yeah it
goes in one minute and two minutes and
four minutes
in one hour how about you just change it
now i'm working right now iphone
don't upgrade automatically but it does
it and the people in charge of our
elections that system can't just
i mean it can't just go to a satellite
and be like hey let's make sure this
thing is flawless
what what kind of update do you need to
make sure that it doesn't switch votes
automatically like hold on that was the
previous version
switches votes to joe biden yeah we need
we need to update it so it doesn't do
that anymore on guys
we know the old version just made the
names disappear
yeah this one actually blue version is
the one that switched the names
the third one is it just doesn't let you
vote at all if you choose the wrong one
the floor opens and you drop it to a pit
right it'd be like if they gave you a
ballot your mail-in ballot two pens and
one pen uh if you were they said if
you're a republican use this and it's
just disappearing
yeah it's just invisible link i don't
see anything i know it'll
it's just it'll appear later right oh
you didn't get a white paint marker
stephen that's what happened to the
election of 1932. oh
the old invisible ink joke yo oh i
should have known
better has there have there been any
switches to this degree for donald trump
you just saw in new hampshire
a five to six percent lead for that
republican just when they did a recount
of the votes now usually if there's no
kind of direct fraud it's like
you'll do a recount maybe a point five
percent difference right this happened
in new hampshire
this has been going on across the
country now i don't want to get into the
get off in a rabbit trap you know we
have heard about
election fraud from the democrats have
we they've been pointing out that there
is no way
that black men women and hispanic men
and women
came out in record numbers to support
this racist president
right and they are trying to find every
excuse they can to say
i don't know what happened right well
the good news is
they uh only came out in record numbers
for donald trump
outside of detroit philadelphia atlanta
so
so yeah it was records number of
minorities and women and then in a few
counties it was a fifth of that
cnn even announced that uh he was taking
detroit when
when i was there yeah and then all of a
sudden overnight he didn't
well
yeah it was it was in the morning wasn't
it either way someone's getting hit in
the head with a bristol board
in detroit as they cover up the pole
stations
they let all the wild roaming deer and
turkey over their votes as well
right downtown this is remarkable when i
just say this out loud but we'll go
through
some of the details here but as far as
passing the sniff test
joe biden got 10 million more votes than
barack obama ever said
like barack obama was charismatic i
watched that guy shoot three pointers
and yeah i don't like him but
i get it joe biden people who voted for
him are like i don't like him
and i don't get it i don't know how this
is the guy our bench left this guy it's
like if you were to go to your second
string players on your bench
and there's a quad amputee they're like
ah put me in coach you're like all right
i figure you're about due she's just
duct taping bats to the nubs
oh right okay just bunch remember bunt
ain't nothing in the rule book says a
quadriplegic
nothing in the rule book it's basically
the water boy but he's not a champion
he's gonna say the water boy actually
can put more sentences together oh
easily
yeah and he doesn't get tired in the
first act
that's true so here's some so that's
michigan now we have two georgia
counties they've been using dominion
software they reported glitches of
course during this election spalding
county georgia which went 60 percent for
trump in 2016.
they were one of the counties with a
glitch that prevented day of voting for
hours remember we talked about that it's
like oh it was a glitch and people just
couldn't vote for hours now keep in mind
people who vote same day tend to be
republican and they tend to be gainfully
employed they can't professionally
protest and burn down walgreens and [ __ ]
so it's very hard for them to wait
several hours
in addition to the lineup so a several
hour shutdown of the system
can lead to a five six seven hour delay
for you to vote
and you actually have a job to get to so
it makes it tough
that's one of the glitches that happened
uh another one um that had happened was
uh in georgia uh where was it um
fulton county i'm trying to see here uh
there's no explanation by the way for
that glitches
for that glimpse whatsoever the
spaulding county there was another
county who's what's the other georgia
county there was another georgia county
can we have ready
i'm going to say either dakob or
gwinnett county well the gwenet i
thought it was in folsom county
fulton also had some issues that's where
atlanta was right it was in atlanta yeah
the right around is around atlanta yeah
oh this is so this is what happened
there was no explanation that was
consistent
uh they tried election officials tried
to say well you know what actually
uh there was a glitch it was due to an
overnight upload problem
and then the representatives for
dominion said no it wasn't
and people said well what was the glitch
they said no i mean i don't know why
you're asking questions didn't you see
that cnn said biden's president yeah you
don't need to worry about that anymore
what happened with it but what is the
glitch
they said it's this dominion says no
it's not there is no answer
do we have any reporters in this country
are there any journalists left
i mean you're gonna do a whole film
about aaron brockovich and water that's
not even as toxic as flint and right now
you have the most
corrupt election of our time right and
you have city election officials going
like oh it happened because of overnight
upload and the people in charge of the
upload saying no it didn't and then
people were going good enough for me
they go just have a cigarette at denny's
well unlike uh
erin brockovich there's no hero to make
a movie about ah
yes not yet yeah it was morgan county
morgan county
morgan county i apologize from reg
i will say this we do have some
reporters at cnn they are covering how
uh our favorite mayor uh rudy giuliani
is actually unwittingly working for the
russians
i swear to you that was what this
morning
is he unwittingly working on behalf of
the russians
are we really going back to that come on
you can't go to the election you can
cover that i wouldn't be surprised if
like dominion servers were in russia
certainly china or you know germany
they're just in the disputed chechnya
area
right yeah no problem it's a little
crazy servers are in georgia well i
guess that makes sense you're doing
votes in georgia like no they're
in georgia the country yeah over there
you gotta go across
uh thousands of miles of ocean why would
you put them there
your guess is as good as mine cheap
space is cnn not still crying
no no oh yeah okay yeah about the uh
well it's funny with cnn that night you
know they didn't expect the mail in
battles this is something too that's
important to know
you know and i said that i wouldn't
because we passed them young turks but
young turks so just briefly and then cnn
msnbc if you look at the reaction on
election night right
until we went they were pissed they were
definitely like i can't believe that
we're losing this how could you make
this mistake again democrats this was
they were pissed in other words when
they say well we knew there was going to
be this
graph because of mail and ballots well
we didn't know and we said before
this uh this this election stream that
we did expect mail-in ballots to be
largely democrat that stands the reason
that's
because one party said you're gonna die
if you go out and have a slight cough
and the other party said hey you should
vote in person to make your vote count
but the democrats what's really
important is just go back in your little
time machine
and watch all of news media and all
democrats let's say at about
11 pm it was like a death march yeah
they thought it was over
we announced it right it's trump yeah so
did we
we're like well listen it looks like
they're gonna because they say they're
gonna stop counting remember
well you know we're gonna stop counting
and start at nine in the morning
and we thought okay i took an hour and a
half nap in the hammock people have
heard the story ad nauseam and i get a
text from audio like yeah they started
counting again i said you're [ __ ]
it was this elementary school telephone
tree and it was like every democratic
chairman called every other democratic
chairman in the precinct
it was like get to go get to go out get
the count yeah what about those votes we
sent you
put them in a coleman cooler and get
them out here i'll put some blue mix
over it we'll say it's camera equipment
yeah thanks to magic all of a sudden
greg kinnear shows up with a bag of
letters from for santa
good news magic everyone oh
joseph biden look at this
i'd like to see him put in a mental
institution greg kinnear
no no joe biden yes if it were a miracle
on 34th street
it would just be uh it would just be uh
it'll soon be
dying in a ward yeah what'll be a
miracle on 25th amendment when they pull
that in
drag them out of feel like you're office
i feel like every time he runs that's
his defense for tripping and falling
forward he's like i gotta run
and what would you like for christmas
little girl kamala harris is president i
think i can pull that off
it should be easy enough now if you
wouldn't mind staying here i'd like to
smell your neck
[Laughter]
i'm a father president can you really
crawl down chimneys
no this is one santa who's coming
through the front door
you'll hear me up the stairs your
parents will open it up for a photo op
and then i'll sniff you like a cologne
ad
i'll come in the front door the back
never ah
is there anything that i'm missing on
dominion and voting fraud with sydney
powell
because we have fraud week all week and
tomorrow i think is georgia we end with
pennsylvania
we're going to have a lot there's going
to be more coming out this week we know
that there's going to be additional
information we've just seen the tip of
the iceberg from
city powell and the other information so
this is the best we could be doing it
stay tuned yeah well so and one thing
you and i talked about this before bill
we need to see evidence very quickly
right if we go too much longer without
seeing hard evidence all we're going to
hear about is cases being thrown out
these kind of more weak cases that were
being brought because it's hard to prove
some of these things right even if they
happened
some people have evidence theory that
they're doing this to buy themselves
time
that they don't expect these cases to
stick so that they can do right big case
which is the voting for the dominion
voting system but they started that a
lot
of water the reason is because remember
we talked about
certification dates a lot of these
lawsuits are trying to either stop or
push back the certification date because
once you get to the certification
threshold right you're you're way far
down the road about trying to then
overturn
it um and that's what you know when you
look at bush v gore and you know saying
okay wait a minute we're going to keep
looking at things we're going to keep
doing our canvassing
so if the democrats are able to say no
no no we don't have to look into the
dominion fraud until afterwards
there will come a point where even if
you prove that there's
a matter like imagine in a year from now
if we were to approve fraud
right what are we going to go back and
just undo everything i mean it'll cause
incredible chaos
so that's why the republicans are making
a huge push now the different lawsuits
in the different jurisdictions
but why the dominion thing is such a
hard thing to look at is
there's no one who is a poll watcher in
the dominion software
right so you're having to be able to put
together more information that you would
normally do
over three six nine months of discovery
depositions
inspections forensic examinations but
you're having to put all of that
together now
in order to do it before the
certification date right right and also
keep in mind they can't really if
they're
if they're trying to trap and i don't
know again i do i sometimes i'm
disappointed where
they present these arguments they just
have a witness that really it's
circumstantial evidence at best and they
don't really provide a whole lot and i
get it we're frustrated but if they
actually do
have the moab right they said they're
going to release the kraken that's what
uh sydney powell said
if they do have that they can't tip
their hand publicly they've got to bet
once and bet
right so exactly i'm hoping that's
what's going on and not just a big build
up to raise money for the legal defense
because if that happens i'm going to be
pissed and donald trump is going to lose
me
in other words if this is not proven
verifiably with these specifics
that this administration has gone out
and claimed i'm going to be pissed and
i'm not going to be in their corner at
that point because you've said you've
got evidence
specifically that relates to millions of
boats of votes being switched boats
being switched right a lot of votes
you voted late tommy the tugboat um so
if they do not prove this specifically
in court
i'm they're going to lose they're going
to lose me as a supporter now i think
there's enough evidence
of of fraud with or at least uh
unconstitutional uh running of the votes
right that happened of course in
different precincts i think that's that
may be enough of an issue
i think it's just so distrust in the
election where if any contract is based
on fraud right it's effectively null and
void
right if people agree that there is no
there wasn't a truthful original basis
for the contract
but i don't know they're claiming the
dominion thing they're claiming the
voting system thing
they better have something otherwise and
here's why i say i think they do
because sydney powell is not someone
who's only worked for this
administration like uh
like uh half-asian bill is saying this
is someone who wants a career after this
administration whether it's now
or four years from now right exactly and
also
um the weather bells you know graham and
mcconnell i mean these guys are
spineless amoebas and for some
they don't they would not tie themselves
to someone losing and for some reason
they have gone all
in defending donald trump they haven't
done that in the past it's been
wishy-washy so it makes me think there's
something there
that we don't know but that's entirely
speculation yeah we'll see it'll come
out and i think one of the reasons that
you see the media doing such a hardcore
press
right now on them to do transitions joe
biden's the president-elect they're now
using covid as leverage for that saying
right if you don't if you don't start
transitioning now we're going to have
problems with this
and the rollout and so everything you
hear is baseless everything takes slower
except for this yeah right except for
this i'm like oh we need to push it
through mean wait wait wait wait wait
wait you guys are telling me that joe
biden had an actual plan
because i remember during these debates
and we're not that long ago in the town
halls
where we were like are you going to pack
the courts i don't know yeah i don't
know what are you going to do what are
you going to do
what are you going to do about cover i
don't know i i don't know it's chief of
staff yeah that's carmella
you mean kamala that's right i would
plan not to [ __ ] his pants but it was
more of a hope
it was really more of a hopeful clinch
yeah hope is not a plan sir
i'm gonna face scrunch not turn any
imodium commercial
and speaking of beverly mitchell has a
corner on that march
speaking of corona look what cnn's
telling us they just said marduna
has a 94 effective vaccine correct don't
you love but we're going to talk about
covert a little bit here uh how uh
the media said that uh rand paul's
anti-science because he said that you're
immune to covet if you catch it and
he's right there wrong but um this is
funny don't you love how uh cuomo
said i wouldn't trust a vaccine from
this administration and i don't here's
the thing i don't know
if there was a reason that uh donald
trump was talking about distributing the
vaccine that it wouldn't go to new york
state like i don't know if there was a
conversation
or he just said it publicly just to
watch his eyes yeah
and we're gonna give it to the whole
country except new york talk to cuomo
about that
he said what and then the other speakers
also acknowledged it that's what i love
like except that governor yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let me say he
didn't want it yeah we're in agreement
yeah y'all agree yeah him and fredo you
know
[Laughter]
uh well fredo maybe he'll be one of the
other cases of people who catch covet
twice so this is the story now that's
been making the rounds
it was happening uh i think saturday
right was soon we were not broadcasting
rand paul made the suggestion that you
are immune to covet
if you have already had it and of course
the left lost their minds
let's look at this is one thing they say
you need to follow the science so i am
going to give you
irrefutable signs and numbers that i
think i think
you will deem to be um as definitive as
science gets and i don't mean like
definitive like there are 57 genders on
a facebook i mean like
actual science with numbers and
percentages but here's the comment that
rand paul made
first but the other thing is is we have
11 million people in our country
who have already had kovit we should
tell them to celebrate we should tell
them to throw away their masks
go to restaurants live again because
these people are now immune
but dr fauci doesn't want to admit to
any of that dr valachi is like oh
that was me until the election occurs
and now it's a good foundation
i just love picturing fauci somewhere in
the white house going hey
hey whoa it's me i don't sound like that
he says
yeah you do you do like do i sound like
that i don't sound like that
oh do i sound like that are you
intentionally changing your voice not to
sound like that
yeah am i seriously a downer guys
wait wait you don't still like me what's
going on it's almost like people aren't
happy to see me
weird i don't know i usually bring zima
um
i share it back
wine coolers you ladies want something
no
i've been wrong ever since that bruce
willis commercial
um so here's that's what uh rand paul
said
and then he was absolutely excoriated by
the left
for not following the science here you
go they just lit him ablaze
and i think that dr paul needs to be
held to a higher standard he is a
physician he is a medical doctor
he knows better than that and to to
pander to this kind of
nonsensical unreality that some people
live in
uh really just baffles the mind
on the republican side of the committee
today came from criminally vague
who tried to suggest that it was a fully
scientifically proven
fact that if you survive a coronavirus
infection
you are absolutely immune to coronavirus
i don't know why he would say that
for viewers out there to correct
misinformation there is no
evidence that if you've been infected
with coca-19 that you're immune from
reinfection for any period of time
well you know what thank you i will
correct misinformation so
there are i don't i know some of you
guys may know because you read the show
map but uh
uh bear with me some of you have not so
there are at the time of this comment
from rand paul
52 million about 250 000 cases of coven
okay a lot yeah 50 53 million 250. okay
um now let me ask this how many would
you guess so out of those because
they're saying there is no science this
has been going on since january
some people have said since before
january right how many would you guess
uh have been reinfected with covet so we
have a sample of 53 million let's round
it just call it 53 million
so for us to definitively be able to say
that at least for a year or so you
cannot recontract kovid
um you would think that it would have to
be a very small number of people who've
contracted they're saying you cannot
make that claim we need to
fact check that misinformation how many
people who have caught covet of the 53
million cases do you think have
recontracted covet
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well maybe if there are a few thousand
or a few hundred
p
and i hear they lied about it the first
time
[Laughter]
not so much of them it was a hospital
yeah
no i have a mono i'm gonna put covert to
be safe more money please
please so by the way and the first one
this is the one where
so people got really scared because
there was one guy that was widely
publicized from hong kong
sorry half asian bill he should be
sorry everyone publicized the saying can
we re-get can we re-get coveted so there
are four total but the first case was a
guy from hong kong and here's the thing
he's a special case because his immune
response
was atypical this is a quote when
doctors tested his blood to look for
antibodies to the virus they didn't find
any
after the first time he had covered that
could mean he either had a weak immune
response
to the virus the first time around or
that the antibodies he made during his
first infection diminished over time but
during his second infection he quickly
developed here's what's important
this is one of the guys who recontracted
covet and by the way he may not have had
covet if you look at this or at least he
didn't have an immune response because
he didn't have antibodies right but that
would make you think second like
who dodged a bullet the first time you
get the second time it's like a game of
russian
roulette with five rounds in the chamber
right yeah and the other three are
freddie mercury
during his second infection he quickly
developed more antibodies suggesting
that the second infection acted a little
bit like a booster to fire up his immune
system
that's probably the reason he didn't
have any symptoms the second time
[Music]
so a guy who has no immune system beat
the virus
twice with no symptoms well let's end
thanksgiving
i've had a sore throat for three weeks
because tim from hr put a guillotine
choke on me improperly i wish i could be
this hong kong gentleman yeah no it was
properly
how do you know testa say so oh do you
feel uh
feel fine yeah but by the way if you're
under 50 years old your body actually
has a higher effective
rate of curing that than the vaccine
it's like 99.98
speaking of numbers especially this body
so i
i don't like when you rub that down
don't let that rope touch the ground
so
and i don't do math very well and my
half asian lawyer bill richmond i
just i it's the luck of the draw not a
math asian noob
that means less than point and i'll
count so you see
zero zero zero zero zero
zero six zeros seven percent of people
who got coveted ever re-contracted
that's
point zero zero zero zero zero
zero seven percent of people who
contracted covet ever actually
reconstructed the disease
so the left wants you to think that you
need to shut down the entire economy and
that it's misinformation because that's
what rand paul was arguing
exactly we have people out there who are
immune they should be going out living
their lives so that
at this point hopefully we can develop
herd immunity which also the left said
oh it's not releasing but now they're
talking about only giving us
enough vaccines to develop herd immunity
the context of rand paul was saying
you are immune throw away your mask go
out and let's restart society so that we
don't destroy the economy for
generations to come
the left is saying no no no no no no we
got to shut everything down
because if you have had the virus it's
anti-scientific to tell people they
can't get it because
really they're they're only 99.9999993
percent likely to not catch it again
and the cases where people have they
didn't have symptoms a second time what
you think
you think people should be willy-nilly
walking around with a 99.999999993
survival rate going to gas stations
without masks
what are you what are you out of your
trees you don't care about it it's not
even the survive it's the
reinfection rate the survival rate 100
for those guys i think all four of them
will still walk it around
oh oh my goodness that is insane well i
think
thanksgiving is
[Laughter]
i mean every person that i talk to no
matter what their politics are
says there's no question that the
messaging from the democrats and the
progressive left about
what the science is continues to change
like remember 37 years ago in march
when we were told don't wear masks right
and we were saying you know
two weeks to two weeks to 15 days to
flatten the curve
50 days to plan the curve then it was
you know don't worry it's gonna be fine
we're gonna get a vaccine now it's
according to cuomo don't trust the
vaccine
right uh everything's gonna be bad now
it's now we gotta shut everything down
again no
but now we gotta wear masks but then you
know because the science proves that six
feet
is gonna make a difference and
absolutely look at the standard that
that doctor you see was like
a hundred percent certain that you
absolutely can't
get it ever again right is that how is
that the standard for mass right that's
standard
and by the way these same people say
there's no science uh that tells us that
uh hormone replacement therapy for young
boys has any deleterious effects
really really because there's actually a
significantly increased likelihood
of cancer specifically prostate cancer
specifically uh
uh testicular cancer if men have high
estrogen levels let's be clear there's
far
more science in on pumping men
particularly pre-pubescent boys full of
estrogen being cancerous
than there is of your chance of
recontracting code if we're going to
talk about science that's settled you
see all the science is out
and listen we don't know about
reconstruct no no you have to it's not
about
here's the thing with science it's just
like the law it's not did they use a
scientific method
is is the scientific standard applied
equally right and when people say oh
let's use a good example the fda
the fda where they talk about cigars so
i occasionally enjoy a pipe or a cigar
right and they lumped when they did a
study with the fda they lumped everyone
in so this is your increased likelihood
of lung cancer and esophageal cancer
right then when they separated pipe
smokers and this is an actual statement
you can bring up from the fda
there was someone who conducted a study
when they could they separated people
who smoked two cigars per day
or less and i think they had like four
pipe bowls a day per less which would be
really high for cigar smoke
right we occasionally have a cigar they
actually found out that
the statistical chance of any more to
increase mortality was zero percent
and the statistical chance of increased
mouth or esophageal cancer
was about four percent less than
non-coffee drinkers to coffee drink
there you go cancer risks nearly nil but
the fda still comes out and goes oh hold
on the science isn't out
if there's a four percent here there's a
point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero seven percent chance how was the
science out on one and not the other
right and that's what the doctor could
have easily said he could have said look
i disagree because we don't know
if definitively yet there is very little
evidence that anybody is going to get
this again and have severe symptoms
we've only had four cases he could have
said all that if he was a doctor
if he says we've only had four cases
he's out of a job as a professional
company
i agree i agree his politics were
getting in the way of him being an
actual doctor
a physician right instead of saying this
is what's going on you can probably go
out and be
let's not ignore the uh let's not ignore
the uh the brotherhood there that uh you
know uh sanjay gupta went in and uh
his cousin's there again what do you say
there dave landau i have no i have no
idea oh really
i'm gonna say that vaping makes uh
99.007 percent chance of looking gay
already yeah but it's right there when
it comes as a birth control device i
but it was inspired by i was in a car
and this guy next to me had lil wayne
who i like of course because he votes
the right way
and uh he was next to me with a vape mod
and it was like purple
and he had like the he had the wheels in
his car that didn't do the jumping
yeah they just elevated it i mean like i
didn't do the full jump a little bit
a little bit of hydraulics and he puts
it up on his lips so this is you know he
goes
and he looks at me oh boy
and blows it out and i said you look
like you're blowing optimus prime
like it was a purple silver device it
looks like you're going down on short
circuit
we're having a threefold yeah look if i
caught my kid with one i would go listen
here's marlboro reds and a cowboy head
yeah or i know i know where there's a
guy who will have sex with you just
don't
look sorry you're going to have sex with
the guy when you're of age the point is
less gay that made it by the way and
don't worry i say this is something that
she won't get twice
that so far guys you just have to treat
it early otherwise you end up
passing off the capone or just the guy
in the white robe it's fine is it okay
to say cuz i'm in a white robe
yeah no i think it makes it definitively
less okay
anything in the white robe and i say
this as someone who occasionally uses uh
uses uh johnny boy's vape i'm not gonna
lie and uh
you have the cbd in there which why do
you gotta blame it on him he just threw
him under the bus
because i feel like it uh so listen
again the question today is dominion
voting
uh if you know that your state is using
what your voting process was like
what confidence you have in it and if
you have followed up on it that's the
question of the day right now we are
going to go exclusively
to mug club for people who are not yet
members crowder election stream is the
promo code you get 30
off until the selection is actually
called and uh it's loudwoodcredit.com
mug club we're about to play steven
knows sports and take your chat youtube
thank you very much
i messed up piss off youtube